Welcome To The Sky News Daily I'm Neil
Patterson today once again we are
discussing Russia now the Russia files
amongst you may well have noticed that
last week President Putin said that any
further movement of troops mobilization
of troops would depend on what his
Warriors
he also talked about whether or not
Russia would once again try to take
Keith
his response on that topic only I can
answer this myself
I clearly hope that that is not the case
but I would suggest that if you are to
understand Russia and to understand
Putin then you probably have to spend
some time there so thankfully that is
exactly what our guest has done Diana
magnate started reporting from Russia at
the end of 2013 just of course before
Russia and its Crimea before becoming
Skies Russia correspondent full-time in
2018 in the last decade well she has
seen plenty of sites and plenty of
changes in Russia she's in the UK at the
moment and here in the Sky News Daily
Studio Dana it is lovely for once to
actually be able to say hello to you in
person because usually whenever we chat
it is via tiny little boxes satellite
dishes and televisions that's true
you're just a voice at the end of my
earpiece normally so it's great to be
here but look Moscow can't have been
your first rodeo so I'm just wondering
in in terms of the places that you have
reported from how does it compare
I mean I've never reported from another
authoritarian State like that it's
totally different what you have to
confront all the time in Russia is that
the possibility that you'll be arrested
and the possibility of what they would
do then and that's the same for
journalists it's for the same for the
Russian people you know it's the law
that you're up against there and that's
what makes it difficult to operate in
but the weird thing is and of course the
restrictions have grown especially since
February the 24th last year but actually
in the day-to-day you know people have
been much warmer on the streets even
though Britain now for Russians is kind
of their mortal enemy they've been
warmer to you they've been more kind of
differential and polite and perhaps this
is because it's quite a reactionary
conservative Society you know in Europe
you get people screaming at you and
going fake news and you know you get
that a lot in the states too and the UK
especially around brexit you don't
really get that yet in Russia and I
suppose it depends how this all evolves
and what whether that hostility will
really grow I slightly felt it actually
on Victory Day the first time people
were sort of stopping and listening to
us and saying just tell the truth and
you know obviously the truth in their
eyes is literally the sort of 100
reversal of what the truth in my eyes is
Victory of course it's like that big
parade that they have annually when you
see all the the equipment and material
and troops going past President Putin of
course front and center in all of this
and I think to an extent for for many of
us here in the west Russia and Putin
have kind of almost become synonymous I
mean over over the decade did you notice
any change in the way in which he
portrayed himself or is he has he always
been you know chest out on the back of a
horse riding through the river or has
there been a softening at all
he couldn't really be sort of bear
chested on a horse in this current
context now I don't think that would go
down well with the general public I
think that we saw this traumatic change
during covid and you know I'm not the
first person to say this but the idea
that he kind of went and borrowed
himself away in his bunker or in his
library and didn't talk to very many
people and read a lot of history books
and sort of construed his his own
version of what the past was and what's
going on now I think that had a major
impact on him but he's he remains you
know a first and foremost a KGB man and
that still absolutely dictates his
mindset in terms of perceiving
everything as a as a threat you know we
love to show those images of him on
Horseback of him kind of in all these
strange scenarios you know these are the
these are the pictures that we always
would have brought to the four before
when we were talking about Putin but I
think that they're the anomaly you know
he's he's pretty much a kind of gray man
in a suit and actually he's always been
that at the beginning of his 23-year
rule he was much more open to the West
that he gradually shut down and here we
are
he may well be wearing a business suit
rather more often than the king of the
khakis but but at the same time I mean
it hasn't a large amount of his his kind
of domestic popularity in Russia is
isn't that directly linked to this kind
of strongman ideal that he portrays and
the the Russia that he wants Russians to
believe in as well yeah I think he wants
Russians to believe that it is a great
country great power commensurate with
its enormous size and you know they can
be part of something great and his
popularity comes from the fact that he's
pitched himself in a way as a sort of
populist he pictures himself always as
listening to the people you know that's
why you have all these appeals directly
to Vladimir Putin it's as though if you
ask Putin to solve your problems they
will be solved because he's put these
mechanisms in place which are then put
out on the television
um where people believe that you know
may not be their Regional governor who
does anything for them but Vladimir
Putin will you mentioned Victory Day
though and and in the past on Victory
people have tended to come out of their
houses holding up pictures of their dead
children children who have served with
the Russian forces and have lost their
lives in in the conflicts that that
didn't happen this year no for for
whatever reason I'm just wondering along
this this idea that you you remain in
private for as long as you can but but
at certain time you can see your control
dwindling I'm just I'm just wondering
does he remain as popular as he once was
with your domestic Russian audience I
think we all wish that his popularity
had slipped as a result of this war but
I've just been surprised to see how much
Russians have rallied around the flag
how much that propaganda just permeates
it's very effective you know first of
all when you turn on state TV what you
see there it's it's well produced it's
like 60 Minutes their main talk show is
on twice or three times a day you know
it's exciting to watch and then there
are all these various talk shows where
they
exceed a million different lines that
land with people in different ways and
the Kremlin it's not just what's on
television there are lots of other
avenues through telegram through other
forms of social media through
advertising that they see ideas with
people that means that you know the
majority of the Russian people can just
grab onto something that will make them
feel better in an uncomfortable
environment which you know everybody now
feels I think in Russia that's what I
mean by the propaganda it's a kind of
vast panoply of different threads that
can appeal to different age groups it's
not just the sort of babushkas who are
watching State tv in the regions it's
across the board
but what what though about is about his
control his grasp on on power in Russia
at the moment I mean you and I have
talked about it in the past I mean you
know the head of the Wagner group for
example operating in Ukraine speaking
with me seeming impunity in negative
terms about what's going on in the
Kremlin I mean over the course of the
decade have you seen his control his
grasp on the reins of power there start
to loosen slightly I don't think Evgeni
pagodian is an indicator that Putin is
losing his grip Putin has always played
groups of people off against each other
because he is scared of anybody becoming
too powerful and I think part of the
fact that he allows pregosian to
basically say what he wants all the time
discredit the Russian Armed Forces as
the only person who is able to is to
make sure that there's a counterweight
really to to the military that nobody in
the military becomes too powerful I
think that's the only reason why Prego
is allowed to keep doing what he's doing
because for the time being he remains
useful
it is his kind of a long term is his
longevity I might even say tight
inexorably to what happens in Ukraine
I think so and I think his own idea of
his legacy is also tied inexorably to
what happens in Ukraine and he can throw
endless resources at it I think the
problem is that it doesn't matter to
Vladimir Putin How many of his own
people he kills in the process as long
as you know there's no popular Uprising
as long as people in the country stay on
his side and he hasn't seen them turn
away from him yet and he's done
everything that he can to suppress even
the tiniest possibility of resistance
so I don't think he feels too worried
about what's going on domestically I
think that those unease amongst the
elites but they're kind of
you know they're bought into the Putin
project they don't really have anywhere
to go and as long as he can keep playing
off different groups within the security
agencies within the military within the
elite make sure that nobody's getting
too powerful which he's a master at and
they're all spying on each other then um
he doesn't really have domestically much
to you know threaten him given the Play
Store of Ukraine in his legacy and he
can't come away from this with nothing
why did we all get it so badly wrong in
the run-up to the Ukraine war yeah you
know you wouldn't invade yeah
ah
I mean I asked myself this question
because I was sure that he wouldn't that
it was all a massive game of
brinkmanship I think we just
underestimated what he was prepared to
do and and at what cost because this has
been a huge cost
[Music]
I mean obviously Vladimir Putin is an
endlessly fascinating man and book after
book after book will be written about
him but your job of course as a reporter
as a journalist is more focused on the
day-to-day and I'm and I'm wondering how
easy it is to do what you need to do to
to get the information that you need to
get the access that you need to get the
you know the contacts within the Kremlin
that you might need I mean we don't get
much access anymore there is a daily
telephone call with Dmitry peskov the
kremlin's press secretary where he does
answer questions which is good but you
know since the start of the war we just
don't get officials speaking to foreign
media particularly a lot of the analysts
who we used to spoke to have left the
country people on an official level are
very scared to talk to foreign media
because it doesn't go down well
domestically we can still talk to people
on the street how's that I mean do you
need to get permission to do that or no
no no no no no I mean you can just go
out and talk to people people are
becoming more hesitant I think
especially younger people in places like
Moscow or St Petersburg recognize that
if they say something wrong that could
for example there was voxpops just
talking to people on the street a series
of those were put on the internet not by
us by a different broadcaster and then
the police came to those people and
charged them with discrediting the armed
forces that makes you feel uncomfortable
you don't necessarily want people to say
things that will incriminate them and P
people are also aware of not saying
things that will incriminate them and I
think what's amazing is that you can
still find people who are brave enough
to speak out and then people are still
happy who support the regime to tell you
why and often it's a sort of incredible
palantly of different ideas that they
have about why what they're doing in
Ukraine is Justified
understandably that the ability of the
of the western media to operate in
Russia is somewhat limited there is of
course the prospect of journalists
actually being sent to to prison let's
talk a little bit about Evan gershkovic
The Wall Street Journal journalist
arrested on on spying charges I mean
that that alone is a concerning
development for anyone who has an
interest in what is going on in Russia
that was awful I mean it is awful Evan
is not a spy
Evan is a great journalist and it is
horrific and it will be a long time I
think before Evan gets out because the
government has told us that any kind of
prison is what would only happen once a
conviction has come down and it will be
a closed case because he's charged with
Espionage and it will probably take
about a year just to get the case to
court so you know every minute that Evan
is in jail is a is a minute too long and
it is grossly unfair and what is so
difficult is that we all believed to a
certain extent before this happened that
for whatever reason they still wanted
foreign journalists to keep doing what
journalists must do and try and tell the
truth and find out what's going on in
the country and this was a a red line
that has been crossed you know all the
Russian journalists the Russian
independent journalists for
investigative Outlets like novegasietta
dodged there were brilliant Russian
journalists inside Russia they're all
operate from outside Russia now because
they all left when these new laws came
into place Banning fake news shortly
after the war came out but foreign
journalists stayed and what's happened
to Evan has had a real chilling effect
and it's it's awful it all seems to be
part of this this Continuum of
repression of dissent within Russia and
I wonder also I mean another name that
people may very well be aware of Alexi
navalny the opposition politician in
Russia himself was taken not long I
think after in fact you started
reporting for us
I mean that is an example I think of an
individual who knew exactly what was
going to happen to him but still felt
the need to go back into the country to
to make the point didn't he yes and I
think there are
um a few figures who are extremely Brave
like that Vladimir caramozo who's just
been sentenced to 25 years on trees and
charges is similar he didn't need to go
back to Russia another human rights
activist Oleg olov who ran essentially
Memorial the human rights organization
that was shut down just before Vladimir
Putin went into Ukraine he's on trial
now for discrediting the Armed Forces
for equating Russia with a fascist
regime basically they all of them they
could have left the country but I think
their idea and Alexia navali's idea used
you can't lead Russian people you cannot
provide an example to the Russian people
you cannot explain to them what their
rights are what they should be fighting
for what freedoms are unless you are in
Russia unless you stand and fall on your
sword
how can you sit in the luxury of a broad
and lecture to Russians about what they
should be thinking and feeling and doing
and you know Alexia navani felt he was a
Russian politician and needed to be in
Russia that's what Vladimir karamoza
felt too and it's an incredibly Brave
upstanding position to take
but if you are an opposition leader you
also need an ability to be able to
communicate with those who are of your
view or those who might be persuaded to
it I mean how are these dissidents able
to communicate with people in Russia you
hear use of services like telegram I
mean does the internet provide any
opportunities to those who would seek to
criticize Putin that that maybe were not
there when you started I mean telegram
is huge in Russia everybody is on
telegram you know I think the Kremlin is
desperately trying to work out how to
how to infiltrate telegram everybody is
on it and therefore there is a lot of
anonymous and interesting reporting on
there and there's you know I said that a
lot of the good investigative
journalists have left Russia but there
are still people working inside
anonymously and putting out fascinating
reporting but it's not so much about can
dissidents get their message out it's
just more and more that people aren't
necessarily listening you know the
repressions that I've witnessed in the
last 10 years since I've been going
there are really brutal you know people
that you've interviewed just one by one
end up in jail
it's it's the same as Belarus you know
if I if I think back to August 2020 when
we were in Belarus and the disputed
presidential elections and people were
just being hauled off the street and put
in the back of paddy wagons and sent to
a crestino and terribly beaten and
tortured and you know consistently those
people who we would follow up with they
would end up in in jail too not because
of our reporting but because they stood
up against the regime and Russia always
tried to be a little less like that
Putin didn't want his system to look
quite as brutal and ohfish as
lukashenko's I don't think but um it is
getting there you know the protests at
the beginning of the war period I
couldn't believe the number of police
out on the streets people would just be
hauled off for walking past and taken
off to police stations so he's managed
very effectively to to crush all
protests I mean Russia the Soviet Union
as well had this capacity to just sort
of expel in huge belches the
Intelligentsia people who are against
the regime it's not a new thing now it's
been going on for a long time
having spent 10 years you know living
alongside ordinary Russians how has that
affected your view of the West listening
to their view of the West I Wonder
I think that in Russia
I've been around people who have been
fighting for things that we take for
granted here I mean it is a cliche but
you know I look around London now and
everybody's sort of coming back from a
Harry Styles concert and having a lovely
time and of course there are a lot of
problems here but we don't have to fight
for very simple freedoms we don't have
to be scared of what we say
and we don't have to be accused of being
you know a terrible people because we
didn't have the courage to to stand up
and do something I mean I think it's
really rich to accuse the Russian people
of having done nothing you know when I
walk around Moscow now I think of every
corner where I've been at another
navalny demonstration people have
protested there for such a long time and
it has got them absolutely nowhere and I
kind of think people in the west need to
take that on board
yes it's disappointing that such large
numbers have bought into this war in
Russia and that goes back to the way
they've kind of accepted State Authority
since Soviet times since Imperial times
and there are a million different
factors that go into that but there were
brave people who tried to do something
about it and there still are and I think
people in the west sometimes need to
realize that they're very lucky well
let's flip that question on its head
then whenever you are outside of Russia
do you miss it uh yes but Russia has a
strange
because I do and Moscow is an amazingly
beautiful city I think and there's a lot
going on there and somehow it gets to
you but then it sort of chews you up and
spits you out I think it's a strange
place
and I hope that
there is a way of distancing Russia and
its history and its culture and and all
the wonderful things about it from this
hideous War
a strange Place perhaps but one made all
the more understandable by the work that
you and your team have been doing over
there Diana so thank you very much and
thanks for joining us on the podcast
thanks for having me
[Music]
and that is your lot from the daily for
today thanks of course to Diana this
episode's one was produced by Rosie
Gillett our editor is Paul sandworth
we'll see you next time
[Music]